ça va comment ça se passe pendant le
confinement ça se passe plutôt pas mal
pour vous dites moi comment ça se passe
si vous pouvez marquer tout de suite en
battant commentaires qu'on déjoue pas
d'une application que gouvernement est
en train de préparer sur laquelle il
travaille on sait pas si elle sortira
tout cas ils travaillent dessus est une
application qui s'appellerait stop
qu'ovide qui aurait pour but de venir
traquer suivre les personnes qu'ils
utiliseraient qu'il aurait sur leur
smartphone pour pouvoir alerter si vous
avez été en contact avec une personne
infectée pour boire vous faire dépister
pour pouvoir donc agir et lutter contre
le corona de nous j'ai donc vous
expliquer comment devrait fonctionner
cette application qu'est ce qu'elle va
récolter comme informations sur vous est
ce qu'elles semblent être en tout cas
pertinente
est ce que l'état va vous espionnez avec
cette application oui ou non pour bien
débuter comme tous les jours je vous
demander de vous envoyer vos vidéos de
confinement savoir comment ça se passait
chez vous à l'adresse qui s'affiche ici
on va donc regarder la vidéo du jour
bonjour monsieur je m'appelle jacques je
suis
retraités actuellement sur l'île de la
réunion
je t'envoie ce message lors de ma petite
sorties journalières au bord du lagon
l'ermitage
je suis possesseur d'un samsung s8 plus
et je serais intéressé par l'open dit
kz2 que tu a présenté brièvement il ya
quelques temps je voulais savoir si tu
allais faire un test complet très
prochainement
voilà je
te souhaite une très belle journée au
revoir
merci pour cette vidéo alors tout
d'abord pourquoi est ce que le
gouvernement planche sur une application
qui a priori s'appellerait stop&go vide
eh bien ils travaillent dessus dans leur
stratégie de déconfinement leur
stratégie de confinement ne reposera pas
sur l'implication mais elle ferait
partie d'un ensemble de dispositions qui
pourrait arriver très prochainement
le but étant d'identifier les chaînes de
transmission en gros de savoir si vous
avez été en contact avec une personne
infectée
le principe est le suivant dans un
restaurant un lieu ce que vous voulez
n'importe quel lieu qui va être ici une
jolie petite maison vous avez une
personne ici qui elle est une personne
qui est infecté autour d'elle vous avez
plusieurs personnes un peu tous les
côtés ça peut être un restaurant ça peut
être un barça peut être tout ce que vous
voulez on parle d'un lieu public et bien
parmi ces personnes vous en avez
quelques unes qui ont l'application qui
est installé on n'y a plus de la moitié
au moment où cette personne là va être
dépistés et elle à l'application stop
qu'ovide 19
eh bien on va pouvoir contacter toutes
les personnes qui étaient autour d'elle
à ce moment là qu'ils avaient
l'application pour leur dire d'aller se
faire dépister sa musique par exemple si
vous vous êtes cette personne là et il y
en avoir vous contacter pour vous dire
de venir vous faire dépister alors
comment ça va marcher ce truc parce que
l'idée c'est pas de traquer tout le
monde de venir suivre toute la
population française est de savoir
exactement où sont les gens ce qu'ils
font en temps et en heure l'idée c'est
pas du tout ça l'idée ce n'est pas de
rajouter une contrainte liberticide qui
viendraient poser un problème
supplémentaire lié aux libertés
individuelles
l'idée c'est une application vous
pourriez télécharger vous sur la base du
volontariat
c'est donc un geste citoyen si vous vous
sentez concerné qui serait quand même
belle de pas aux frontières concernés et
bien vous allez agir pour venir stopper
ou en tout cas freiner la propagation du
corps d'un virus alors ça c'est bien
beau mais comment ça marche parce que
moi je vois ça je me dis ok donc le
gouvernement sait exactement où est ce
que je me situe à un instant t ils
connaissent donc tous mes déplacements
grâce à cette application et au final
c'est un peu flipper sauf que l'idée en
fait c'est pas ça du l'idée c'est de
votre application pas fonctionné grâce
au bluetooth et sipa jo localisation il
n'utilisera pas votre gps il va pas y
avoir de triangulation on ne saura donc
pas ou est ce que vous êtes
on sort de ce que vous avez été en
contact avec une personne malade comment
ça marche ça c'est le porteur qui ait
infecté et qui a son smartphone avec
l'application d'installer ça c'est vous
vous avez votre smartphone est pour
l'instant
vous n'êtes pas malade vous devez avoir
le glou tous
activé sur votre smartphone vous avez
bien évidemment l'application stuff
qu'ovide 19 d'installer 500 les deux
prérequis vos smartphones vous venir
communiqué l'un avec l'autre qu'ils vont
en gros venir s'échanger des données
dans un sens et dans l'autre c'est pas
stocké dans un claude je ne sais où
non c'est stocker uniquement en local
dans le smartphone de chaque personne et
en plus de ça ça va être complètement
cryptée ce qui veut dire que c'est
sécurisé en quelques heures sa superbe à
l'aise et bien une perte et tout ça mais
globalement je vois pas trop l'intérêt
tout ce qu'ils vont réussir à voir je
pense potentiellement ça va être votre
numéro de smartphones parce que
qu'est-ce qui va transiter comme
informations les deux smartphones vous
dire on s'est rencontrés tel jour à
telle heure et voilà le numéro de
téléphone de la personne que j'ai
rencontrée donc aucunes données de
géolocalisation titre est stocké ici et
dès lors que cette personne là est
reconnu comme étant affectés on va venir
récupérer les données pour vous
contacter soit par sms soit par
téléphone je sais pas comment ça va se
faire pour venir vous dire venez nous
voir
eh bien vous faire dépister donc trouve
que le choix fait par le gouvernement
d'utiliser le bluetooth est quand même
extrêmement rassurant en termes de
données de vie privée ça bien évidemment
on le prend à l'échelle de deux
personnes qui se croient que vous le
mettez à l'échelle d'une population
totale ça vous permet donc de faire
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important identifiait les malades
devenir ensuite testé les autres et de
pouvoir trier les populations vous êtes
malade vous êtes isolé
qu'est-ce que vous soyez guéri et ça sur
l'ensemble de la population alors ça
c'est bien mais il ya quand même pas mal
de limites
on peut donc se demander si ce
dispositif va fonctionner la première
limite c'est l'adhésion de la population
est ce que vous êtes d'accord que votre
smartphone puissent communiquer nos
smartphones stockés à minima votre
numéro de téléphone pour pouvoir en tout
cas vous contacter il faut vraiment une
adhésion forte de la population pour ça
fonctionne si vous avez ne serait-ce que
20% à population qui utilise cette
application il n'y aura pas de résultat
qui me semble en tout cas suffisamment
significatifs
la deuxième limite c'est une fois vous
voulez télécharger votre application
c'est bien mais il faut que vous
et activer votre bluetooth en permanence
et que vous ne l'ayez pas désactivé pour
je ne sais quelle autre raison sinon ça
ne marcherait pas et la troisième limite
c'est qu'il y ait des tests en grande
quantité pour qu'on puisse venir tester
toutes les personnes qui ont été en
contact avec une personne infectée
maintenant la question c'est est-ce qui
a un côté un peu liberticide est ce que
l'état via pas un peu trop empiéter sur
nos données personnelles
eh bien écoutez moi je pense pas du tout
c'est extrêmement leitza reposerait en
tout cas sur le volontariat et non pas
sur ce qu'on peut retrouver notamment en
corée du sud c'est à dire finir traquer
tout le monde en permanence
ils ont à proximité si l'on peut savoir
avec qui ils sont tout le temps pour des
données de santé publique
aujourd'hui la strate du gouvernement au
mois elle est clair c'est de proposer
des outils mais qui viennent respecter
les libertés individuelles le problème
qu'on a là dedans c'est toujours ou
est-ce que vous placez le curseur entre
une protection forte que ce soit en
termes de santé en termes de sécurité et
les libertés
ou est ce que vous le mettez par rapport
au bien commun et par rapport à la
population l'a priori le choix qui sera
fait par gouvernement c'est de respecter
les libertés individuelles et partir du
principe que rien des ions de la
population forte et globale pour venir
lutter activement en pleine connaissance
de cause
on parle de vie application qui n'est
pas encore disponible qu'il le serait
dans les semaines à venir on va donc
attendre de voir ce que nous propose le
gouvernement mais dites moi vous dès
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous seriez
prêt à sacrifier comme libertés
individuelles pour venir lutter contre
coronavirus et est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut sacrifier des libertés
individuelles pour réussir à lutter
contre cette pandémie vous invite à
marquer tout ça on va aux commentaires
c'est un sujet discussions extrêmement
intéressant je vous invite vraiment
avoir des commentaires constructifs sur
ce je vous embrasse
ce rendez-vous dès demain pour continuer
à parler peut-être allée des bisous et à
demain
[Musique]